okay we uh we have audio we have video
we uh I guess those are really the only
senses that we're dealing with here it
is a stream after all welcome into the
new David Pakman show studio this is
very very exciting I've done a very bad
thing which is that I haven't done
YouTube live streams for a long time
basically we've been in like a many
month period of realizing we have to
move studio preparing to move the studio
finding a new studio politican summer
vacations rotating among staff no good
internet connection with which to do a
reliable stream and finally now we have
the new studio we have sound insulation
we have asymmetrical gigabit internet
which hopefully will hold out for this
stream so I've got to get back into live
streaming there have been a lot of
people angrily telling me they will not
donate on patreon they will not become
man my hair is out of control
they will not become YouTube channel
members they're not gonna do anything
that I want them to do is the long and
short of it until I get back to
live-streaming so in advance of maybe
doing a live stream for election results
tomorrow night even though I know a lot
of people already said David don't even
bother because people we like more are
doing streams so like just don't even
bother in any case it seems like it's a
good day to try to do a stream so the
title about me coming clean on my
political orientation I'm going to be
taking and I'm gonna see if I can get
all of this stuff set up properly for
people to see I hope that I can I'm
going to be taking the I side with 2018
midterm voter guide that's not a bad
shot I can put myself in a box now of
literally and figuratively and you can
see what I'm what I'm doing so this is
gonna be good I am going to be taking
the I side with voter quiz shortly and
you're gonna be able to watch me take it
and I hope some of you will take it
alongside me and maybe super chat me
your results I am going to be doing the
because increasingly there is this there
is this sort of split on the Left I mean
we know I it's it's there splits in
politics there are tracks I don't think
it's a terminal split but there is
increasingly a wing of the left that
says I am a faux progressive that I'm
not the real progressive there are also
those who believe that those calling me
a faux aggressive are actually the not
real progressives so I'm gonna take the
quiz and we'll see where we shape out I
don't know yet I I can I just answer the
questions honestly the only way that I
know how and we will get somewhere and
ultimately we will know which
politicians I aligned with and I hope to
hear from you as well because I know
that there are people who don't agree
with me in our audience and that's fine
so before we get started let's just
refresh it's been a while since I've did
a stream let's uh since I've done a
stream let's refresh sort of the basics
most of our videos are not live the
streams are live unless you're watching
a replay you can use the super chat
function that's the dollar symbol at the
bottom of the chat window to ask
questions and send comments I am going
to be getting to those in a little bit
new members and patrons get live thank
you so I'll talk about that momentarily
david pakman.com slash membership
patreon.com slash david packard show
please don't troll the live chat it's
just annoying
you know it's annoying to me it's
annoying to people who are here to not
be trolled and we had moderators I don't
know if they're here it's been so so
long since I did a live stream I hope
that that some of them are here and they
will monitor the chat and become a
youtube sponsor you know it's funny it's
been so long long since I streamed
YouTube sponsorship sponsorship is now
called YouTube channel membership and I
will announce those during the stream
them the latest is Brody Andrew Mulligan
he's the latest new member
Tito's journey signed up before that
Jackson Perkins before that so a lot of
different ways to you know get get get
attention I guess is what we're going to
say I will mention briefly I have done
such an embarrassingly bad job of
promoting patreon for like the
six months that we've dropped from about
2,000 patrons all the way down to 1643
as of just before I went live so just a
couple things if we get to 1675 during
the stream I'll open up the phone lines
and people can actually call into the
show okay right now the phone lines are
closed I am able to open the phone lines
at absolutely any time don't tempt me
because I'll do it
but just to do something if we get to
1675 patrons you I will open the phone
lines and if we get to let why not just
to add something else if we get to 1,700
patrons during the stream I will play a
live game of chess for you and just to
prove that I'm serious and then I'm not
scared of revealing how poor a player I
am I have Lee chess ready to go here and
as some of you see I'm David Pakman on
Lee chess if you want to challenge me or
add me or whatever there if we get to
1,700 patrons I will play a live game of
chess I'm pulling out all the stops
because it's been so so long since we
did this okay so I I guess if there's no
nothing else to do I guess I should just
get into the voter guide right and I
should just start going through and
let's figure out exactly what my
political orientation is and we'll see
where where we come out I'll just jump
right in this is by the way I side with
dot-com if you want to do this along
with me if you are doing it I hope you
will post your results via super chat I
don't even know what the results look
like if they are if they tell you
candidates or or whatever so let's just
jump in should the president be able to
authorize military force against
al-qaeda without congressional
congressional approval for me the answer
is no and I would I would rank this as
more important I wouldn't say most but
it's pretty important right I mean but
we have a system in place that one of
the most important elements of our
political system is where do the powers
of different branches and areas of
government where are the limits to those
powers so I think that this is an
important thing should the United States
assassinate suspected terrorists in
foreign countries I believe the answer
is no and I would I would also call that
more
important call me crazy I think that
that's an important thing what's your
stance on abortion I am pro-choice I
don't think that will come as a surprise
and you know that this is one we're
ranking the importance is kind of a
little tougher because it's sometimes
when something is really obvious to us
where our politics are we think it's
much more important or sometimes we
might be tricked into thinking because
it's so obvious for me it's less
important and I think what matters is
how many people are affected by this
issue and abortion rights are connected
to so many other important issues
including women's rights including
issues related to the Supreme Court and
so much else so I'm going to say that
that abortion is more important should
the government continue to fund Planned
Parenthood I would say absolutely yes
I'm gonna call that and I know some
people might be upset with this I'm
gonna leave that as somewhat important
it's not that I don't get the importance
of Planned Parenthood but I think that
Planned Parenthood the funding of
Planned Parenthood is its importance
varies depending on other things going
on in the political climate including
the stigmatizing of of abortion and
other things so I'm gonna leave it as
somewhat because I think there are other
ways that we could still be okay without
Planned Parenthood being funded if
certain other things changed that being
said I do believe we should fund Planned
Parenthood so I'm saying yes do I
support the legalization of same-sex
marriage yes and I'm going to call that
more important should I by the way
should I check in to see what are people
upset with me already for some reason
people oh the progressive voices here
which is great I was on his show
recently people ask me why I'm a
socialist I'm not okay so so the chat is
going basically basically as I
anticipated so I'm gonna get back to the
voter guide okay should the government
increase environmental regulations to
prevent climate change yes and I would I
would rank this as most important
because at this point climate climate
change in the environment is our issues
is an issue of importance
multi-generationally of irreversible
potential meaning that we are doing
damage that may be extraordinarily
difficult to reverse it's one of the
most important issues right now it's a
national security issue so the answer is
yes
should the u.s. withdraw for the Paris
climate agreement the answer is no and
that is at the very top and this is not
I don't believe that the Paris climate
agreement is the be-all end-all of
fixing climate change and in fact I have
a pretty realistic and kind of cynical
view about it but it represents
willingness to work together with other
countries to deal with this issue and
being an outlier as Trump is making us
by pulling the United States out it's
just an embarrassment and we absolutely
should not withdraw from the Paris
climate agreement should the government
stop construction of the Dakota access
pipeline yes and I I'm gonna say that
this is one of the more or most I guess
you know the the most important issue is
getting off of fossil fuels Dakota
access pipeline is part of that I guess
I would say most I guess I would say
most now I have the option here of
answering more environmental questions
I'm gonna skip that in the interest of
not making this endlessly long I think
that there are probably enough questions
here to assess my politics economic
issues should the government make cuts
to public spending in order to reduce
the national debt let me just look at
other stances oh these I mean I think I
might just stick to the I'm gonna say no
on this I have made it very clear that
the discussions of debt and deficit have
become political footballs often being
carried out in merely partisan ways by
people who don't even know the first
thing about how debt and deficit works
so to answer the question as as written
which is I guess what I'm trying to do
should the government make cuts to
public spending in order to reduce the
national debt that that's not the basis
on which cuts to public spending should
be made cuts should be evaluated and
made on the basis of economic stimulus
on the basis of what kind of a country
we want to be but not merely to say that
we cut the debt because we're just not
going to cut our way to a good economy
should the u.s. raise taxes on the rich
so I'm
say yes and this oh and I didn't mark
importance I'm sorry here should the so
I'm gonna say that the I'm gonna leave
that last one is somewhat important
should the US raise taxes on the rich
this is more important to me I believe
the answer is yes but I don't think that
we should be necessarily raising taxes
on individuals that are already in the
top tax bracket at the bottom of the top
tax bracket I sort of have I've seen a
number of different analyses as to what
tax rates maybe should be and I think
that we need some very aggressive taxes
at the top but I'm less interested in
raising the taxes of people earning two
hundred and seventy five thousand
dollars a year for example I think that
when you look at the tax revenue
implications of looking at the the real
top I think that that's much more
important so yes I think the US should
raise taxes on the rich I may just
disagree with some on the left as to
exactly where the kind of gradations
should be should the government raise
the federal minimum wage the answer is
yes this is a top issue and you know the
important thing to understand about the
minimum wage is we can sometimes get
pulled into not false debates but
debates that are happening at the micro
level and don't necessarily go to the
systemic change that we need so is the
minimum wage federally too low
absolutely does raising is the debate
around eight ten twelve fifteen or
seventeen dollars the debate that by
answering the top number changes the
economic system which has been a
corporate ah cracy of four to six
decades in the making
growing corporate no it doesn't change
all of that stuff but I do think that
that the federal minimum wage needs to
go up let me just check in quickly with
what's going on with what's going on in
the comments just to see how I'm doing
people talking about 25 bucks an hour
we've got a couple super chats coming in
which I will get to every soup
chat by the way people unsure what the
video is about
I guess just watch the video to figure
that out okay let's get let's keep going
here we're about halfway through should
Internet Service Providers be allowed to
speed up access to popular websites that
pay higher rates at the expense of
slowing down access to less popular
websites no basic net neutrality
question one of the most important meta
issues right now I don't even know that
I need to spend much time on this one
for our audience most of you know how I
feel about this this is a top top issue
how politics is financed media coverage
of politics these are like the top
issues that we're dealing with and they
impact just about every political issue
you or I might care about
so no internet service providers should
not be allowed to do that should there
be more restrictions on the current
process of purchasing a gun I would say
yes I am gonna mark this more rather
than most important and the reason why
is not about me ignoring gun violence
thinking that gun violence isn't a
problem minimizing it being against gun
safety regulations it's just the this is
a ranking and I would put climate change
the status quo of corporate power
lobbyists industrial complex campaign
fine you know that that's just above gun
control for me and that's not to devalue
or dismiss the fact that lives are lost
every single day as a result of guns I
am in favor of decriminalizing drug use
I think that that's a very important
issue it relates to criminal justice it
relates to incarceration our legal
system it relates to the focus on street
crime over white-collar corporate crime
very obvious easy one for me should
health insurers be allowed to deny
coverage to individuals who have a
pre-existing condition my answer is no I
think this is one of the most important
issues and it's listen I'm a social
democrat which means I believe in a
mixed economy I believe in a capitalist
system that is well regulated that
doesn't let people fall behind and it
allows us to say once you've gotten to a
certain degree of wealth
the additional accumulation of wealth is
actually a detriment to society and at
the very top and at the very bottom we
want to kind of compress so that we
minimize the wealth gap and one of those
areas is on health insurance and the
costs of health care and health coverage
anybody hear that what was that that
seems to have been where did that that
noise come from
I guess it's say oh okay that's a super
chat noise okay so when we hear that
that means that a super chat has come in
so let's sum some things should be
outside of profit I think education
should be outside of that health care
should be outside of that and I think if
you want to play in the insurance game
at minimum you shouldn't be able to deny
people with pre-existing conditions
should the government increase funding
for mental health research and treatment
I think the answer is yes do I support
the legalization of marijuana very easy
it's a yes and it's an important issue
don't need to spend too much time on
that let's go to education do I support
increasing taxes for the rich in order
to reduce interest rates for student
loans you know my view is more nuanced
on this because I the current system we
have for student loans is disgustingly
predatory but I think that as big a
problem as student lending is the fact
that we've let educational costs spiral
out of control there are so many other
areas in which we need to deal with
education so would I would I
specifically increase taxes for the rich
to reduce interest rates for student
loans you see what other stances there
are yes an increased government funding
so every student gets free college no
but we should still reduce interest
rates no transition government student
loans and to privately managed accounts
no uh this really is a tough one I think
the the cleanest thing would be no but
we should still reduce interest rates
for student loans for me the connection
between taxing the rich and student loan
interest rates is not an obvious one and
I support increasing taxes on the rich I
just don't know that I'd say
specifically for this reason do I
support
in core national standards man this is
this is complex because I don't maybe
it's just that simple right I mean it
maybe maybe no but is necessary and I'll
just say no do I support charter schools
ah this is this is one of those that is
more complex see what other options we
have yes but not at the expense of
funding public schools the entire
education system should be privatized
that's a no-no we should work on
improving wages and improving schools I
think I would say you know I there are
circumstances in which charter schools
make sense but the main problem I have
is that it destroys public schools so
I'm gonna say I do in some sense support
charter schools but not at the expense
of funding public schools and this is a
very important issue okay foreign policy
should every eighteen-year-old citizen
be required to provide at least one year
of military service but the answer for
me is no I would be open to
restructuring the system we have to
require some kind of either military or
community or nonprofit service as a gap
year between high school and college but
the way things are right now and with
the question as asked I don't think that
every eighteen-year-old citizen should
provide a year of military service I
think if we just simply left the system
as it is and did that it would make it
even easier to get engaged in more
conflicts around the world most of which
are really really bad ideas and that's
uh not something I can get behind
should the u.s. accept refugees from
Syria my answer is yes in the sense that
there's no particular reason that we
should say we're not going to accept
refugees from Syria am I saying that we
need open borders of course not
am I suggesting that there shouldn't be
betting absolutely not but we should not
simply put a country on the list and say
we're not going to accept people from
there last question and foreign policy
should the government increase or
decrease military spending decrease very
important issue listen
the amount that we spend on the military
is absolutely depraved and ridiculous we
have something like 40 bases in Germany
alone we could we could shut down a few
bases and do okay so we decreasing
military spending is one of those issues
that you get branded immediately as
unpatriotic if you don't if you're not
willing to increase military spending
indefinitely we have by far the biggest
military we have more weapons and
nuclear weapons than we could ever use
and we absolutely need to do that period
no this one's just easy for me okay
let's get into criminal issues and I
should monitor other things that are
going on like in the chat and elsewhere
I should see what's going on with
patrons because it seems like people are
maybe interested in in me taking calls
and we'll finish this thing up how are
we doing with patrons I by the way if we
get to 1675 patrons I will open the
phone lines and and people can call in
we'll get to that briefly should police
officers be required to wear body
cameras right now my positions yes and I
know that there are some on the Left who
have emailed me and said David look at
this study or that study that suggests
that putting body cameras on police
officers can change the dynamics of
engagements with imagine that that word
is even a hostile word of interactions
with people on the street citizens
residents etc it can make it can put
police in danger by making them fear
that they might be incorrectly be
accused of using too much force right
now the preponderance of studies I've
looked at indicate very positive results
from police wearing body cameras so I'm
in favor of that should convicted
criminals have the right to vote you
know this question is unclear to me
because it's not it doesn't say whether
it's while they are in prison or after
the fact but I'm going to say that the
answer is yes and and not even worry
about which they mean I completely
understand
there is a legal case to be made that
while you are incarcerated you have
given up in the same way that the
government has effectively decided you
no longer get to be free
I think illegally you can make the case
that while in prison convicted criminals
shouldn't be allowed to vote but I'm
against that I think that can convict
the criminals should be allowed to vote
both while they are incarcerated and
absolutely after the fact very easy one
for me do I support mandatory minimum
prison sentences for people charged with
drug possession absolutely not and the
entire mandatory minimum sentence sort
of industrial complex for lack of a
better term is connected to the criminal
criminalization of drugs it's connected
to so much other sort of MIS use of the
justice system and the of law
enforcement in the judicial system I'm
against it does that mean that I think
no drug-related crime whatsoever
warrants prison time of course not not
saying that not really hearing anybody
on the Left say that either electoral
issues should a photo ID be required to
vote I believe the answer is no and the
reason that the answer is no and I'm
ranking this most important because this
goes to the more than decade-long system
of voter disenfranchisement that has
been perpetuated by the right in the
United States in principle there's
nothing inherently wrong with saying you
need to present a photo ID to vote in
practice we know that obtaining those
IDs may in and of itself be free but the
documents often required to get that
photo ID are not free if you don't have
them and those who are in positions of
disadvantage with regard to paying for
those preliminary documents getting
transportation to the offices where you
can get those photo IDs are
disproportionately poor and in the
United States based on our
graphics are disproportionately
non-white so the the application of
these photo ID laws is discriminatory in
nature and I'm against it should the
Electoral College be abolished you know
we've been talking about this for a long
time if if I have to just pick yes or no
which it seems like I sort of do I would
probably say yes now there are more
options yes and switch to ranked voting
yes and switched to a representative
democracy system no but the balance of
votes by population should be updated
I'm just gonna play it clean and say yes
I think the Electoral College should be
abolished but that doesn't tell us
necessarily what exactly it should be
replaced with and I've talked about
ranked choice voting systems that are
better and some that are not quite so
good which can actually lead to the
winner being someone who was no one's
first choice but that's not really what
it's asking the question is simply
should it be abolished and I believe
that it should should foreigners
currently residing in the United States
have the right to vote as asked I'm
gonna say no when it says currently
residing that could mean legal permanent
residence it could mean people here on
student visas and and it could mean
other people with other statuses so as
asked excuse me as asked I would say no
although I'm open to the idea that
permanent residents should be allowed to
vote should the government increase
spending on public transportation yes
and and this is a very important issue
and as I talked about earlier on the
program today
not only does public transportation
relate to issues of inequality and
economic justice and the perpetuation of
trans generational poverty when people
are born bye-bye through no fault of
their own into a neighborhood that has
poor public transit because it is a less
wealthy neighborhood as is the case here
in Boston for example they then are at a
disadvantage to get out of that
situation merely because they happen to
be born in a poor neighborhood if that
makes sense so that's an important issue
and also
transit relates to issues of voter
disenfranchisement because it's more
difficult for people to go and vote
depending on where you live when public
transit is not good so the answer is yes
should the u.s. build a wall along the
southern border you know I was asked
about this on that that wacky Jesse Lee
Peterson show not long ago I actually
don't have a problem with the wall in
principle but if what you want to do is
curb undocumented immigration the walls
going to cost you a lot of money only
deal with a fraction of that immigration
and it is being used as a proxy towards
extraordinarily xenophobic and and and
racist ideas so I believe that the
answer is no although I don't think in
practice there's anything inherently
wrong with the country saying we're
going to put up a wall but it's the
reasons why we're looking to do it
what it will cost the lack of
effectiveness that even curbing the
problem we claim to want to solve it's a
political football like many others
should adults that are illegally
attempting to cross the US border be
separated from their children some of
these quiet I'm against the policy as it
currently stands to be clear let's see
what else is here
yes criminals don't deserve special
treatment yes it allows officials to
verify the children are not being
trafficked no but immediately deport
them and their children no families
should be kept together while they are
being processed no and we should make it
easier for immigrants to legally enter
the country I agree with a lot of these
I think families should be kept together
while they are being processed I also
believe that we should make it easier
for immigrants to legally enter the
country but you can't choose more than
one here so I'm going to say that
families should be kept together while
they're being processed but if you are
crossing illegally that that doesn't
excuse you're not excused from the fact
that you're crossing illegally merely
because you have kids with you should
immigrants be deported if they commit a
serious crime No so if you are here and
undocumented that's a very specific
situation if you are legally permanently
residing in the United States and you
commit a serious crime a few different
things come to mind number one who
gets to decide what the serious crimes
are and does that change based on the
whims of whoever is in power so we might
say listen we're not looking to target
immigrants in a particular way but if
you commit murder you get deported but
other crimes aren't on that list and
then someone else can say well you know
murder really shouldn't be the only
thing there and we're going to start
expanding the list I I don't like that
these immigration decisions should be
binding in a sense once you have
permanent residency if you've immigrated
and you you have become a citizen as I
have
I don't believe deportation should be on
the table science should the government
require children to be vaccinated for
preventable diseases I'm not there yet
you know I think that absolutely the
government should it's fine for any
public school to say if you want to go
to our school you've got to be
vaccinated I've been for that for a very
very long time my only concern about the
government requiring vaccination period
is I am hesitant to buy into slippery
slope arguments when I don't think that
they are realistic but with the
government requiring vaccination period
not if you're going to a public school
not if you're working at a public
universe
I actually do worry about the slippery
slope so I'm gonna say no on this one
although my mind could very much be
changed on the basis of a proposal that
would limit it merely to vaccinations I
am completely open to that and I've said
it before should producers be required
to label genetically engineered foods
I'm on a yes right now although I'm not
against GMOs and I've not seen any
evidence that food by virtue of being
genetically modified is bad for you I've
seen no evidence other than one study
involving rats which has been debunked
as having poor poor statistical methods
so right now I would say yes let's label
it although I think eventually this is
not going to be an issue and when people
are not going to be really worried
about this probably in 15 to 20 years do
I support the use of nuclear energy
instead of what I'm gonna say no because
I if you said do I support the use of
nuclear energy in very narrow
circumstances as a bridge off of fossil
fuels I would say yes do I support the
use of nuclear energy big picture
potentially as far as the questions
worded instead of saying we're going
full in on renewables and green energy
the answer is no okay it looks like some
trending which party do you identify
most identify with I don't know that I
need to answer this stuff local issues
okay I don't think I need to answer
those and quality let's just look at the
results and see what I get here we go
this is very very imagine if I side with
like Gary Johnson or libertarians or
something like that
the tension is killing me here here we
go Elizabeth Warren 77%
the following shows the percentage of
issues you side with for the candidates
running in the Massachusetts Senate
election Elizabeth Warren no surprise
and yeah I'm familiar with both of these
Republicans and I'm not surprised that
Jeff Diehl is the guy I'm on board with
less 80 83 percent with J Gonzales that
makes sense
he is the Democrat running but let's
look at presidential I think that that's
going to be more interesting Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie Sanders and Oprah that
is interesting so no real surprise here
right Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders my guess is that that's so close
that even without changing my answers
but maybe having changed the relative
importance of some of the answers it
could have ended up flipped Bernie and
Elizabeth Warren so nothing really
surprising here not surprisingly also
that the Republican whose highest on my
list is John Kasich at 48% I don't think
surprising to anybody and followed by by
Mitt Romney and and Rand Paul and again
Mitt Romney a Republican who's a little
more moderate on social issues Rand Paul
Rand Paul's libertarian streak probably
explains why he is also one of the
Republicans that's annoying one of the
Republicans that I agree with more so I
don't think that this is in the least
surprising that Elizabeth Warren and
Bernie Sanders as the two most
progressive senators are the ones that
would be the moat the ones most aligned
with me as presidential candidates so is
anybody surprised by this I don't think
so I think that by the way maybe we
should also analyze the issues on which
I disagree with these individuals my
guess is because I may be to their
left/right like in other words the 18%
I'm not with Elizabeth Warren on is it
because I'm to her writer to her left I
don't know that it tells us that but I
think it would realistically be because
I'm I'm to her left although I guess
what if I click on her name I don't know
what that's gonna tell us too much more
yeah seems like I am I am with around a
lot of these ultra yes he's some of
these so so I just said no internet
service providers shouldn't be allowed
to speed up access to popular websites
her answer is similar no treat all
traffic equally and continue the
openness of the internet that was under
more options but it's basically the same
position like by saying no I'm
effectively saying what she said so I
guess this gives us an estimate but but
nothing is exact okay so I did it I
guess I am a progressive right dad I
don't know I didn't if if your favorite
progressive took this test would they
come out drastically different the
different from me I don't know it seems
like they'd be pretty similar let's okay
what do we want to do next let's check
out so I said that if we get to 1675
patrons tonight I would open up the
phone lines at six one seven eight three
zero forty seven fifty and people can
call in and talk to me and will answer
I'll answer questions we'll see what's
on people's
we've only had two new patrons that I
can see while we've been doing this
stream and we're up to 1645 people don't
want me to take calls
I won't take calls but I think it would
be a really great thing to open up the
phone lines and hear from people on the
eve of the midterms have you voted have
you had problems voting have you taken
the I side with dot-com test so you just
have to do a dollar and if only like
seven percent of the people watching the
stream right now do $1 a month we'll get
to 1675 patrons like that and I will get
the phone lines opened up and in the
meantime let's go over and to deal with
some of the super chats I've seen a
bunch of super chats come in here let's
see what we've got
it's Mao sent a $2.00 super chat saying
only orange man bad alright hope that
was worth it for you I think orange man
bad is this new meme isn't it a meme
from the right which sort of seeks to
imply it seeks to sort of patronize any
criticisms of Trump as he's just a bad
guy no no Kourtney Hanes $2 Super chat
have you ever considered a tiered
minimum wage yeah I don't know Courtney
if you're thinking about it as tiered on
the basis of the industry or the job
level like entry level versus mid-career
versus beyond that I've seen some
proposals but if I were to consider a
tiered minimum wage it would have to be
from a robust minimum wage and up not as
an excuse to create even lower minimum
wages if that makes sense
money daddy sent a to British pound
super chat are trigger warnings a free
speech issue no they are not I think
that trigger warnings are a problem but
a much smaller problem than the right
likes to pretend that they are I've been
all over the issues about safe spaces
and the D platforming of totally
legitimate speech on campuses like I've
not shied away from that issue it's just
important to realize that those issues
get way more attention than the
proportion of college campuses and left
wingers and social justice warriors
then they actually represent and trigger
warnings are not a free speech issue now
Darth bribe bribe boy sent a five-dollar
super chat I took several political
compass quizzes and I came out as a
libertarian socialist every time the
right stole the word libertarian yeah
you can be a left or right libertarian
and for the most part now when people
say libertarian they're mostly talking
about that kind of libertarian not not a
sort of civil leftist libertarians that
somebody sent a five-dollar super chat
and then retracted the message and I
don't know who it was and maybe we don't
even get the five dollars so thank you
but I don't know Darth Bry boy sent the
five dollar super check also would you
be interested in coming on my channel
for an interview in December I'm not
familiar with your channel I don't know
anything about it interview requests
best thing to do is submit it using the
contact form at david pakman.com Omar
Nasir sent a ten dollar super jet hey
David do you think we should approach
people like conservatives who don't
believe in fact but fear and hatred Tom
Nichols death if of expertise a book I
highly recommend on such an issue let me
see if I understand it how do you think
we should approach people like
conservatives who don't believe in fact
but fear and hatred okay yeah that's
tough so six months ago I would have
said you have to approach the people who
are sort of voting on emotion by making
an argument that would appeal to their
values and since then I've actually read
a lot of material suggesting that it's
actually not a good idea to try to
engage with people on values that are
theirs but not values that you share
because in the long term it's not a good
strategy so I don't have a good answer
right now if you watched my clip earlier
today about it's a waste of time to
fact-check Trump Trump I don't literally
mean it's a waste of time to fact-check
Trump and Trump esteem een is that when
you're in a situation where we're trying
to convince people to vote in a
particular way or to interfere with the
Trump agenda they have so successfully
primed the pump
for anything that doesn't go along with
their views to be considered fake news
and for the value of truth to be sort of
subjugated and made second secondary or
even tertiary to whether it seems as
though we're appealing to the right
emotions I don't know what the answer is
I don't know how to deal with those
people at this point let's see the
unseen asks do you think Bernie Sanders
can win against Donald Trump in the 2020
election are there any other populist
left candidates you think have a chance
I do believe that Bernie could defeat
Trump in 2020 does that mean that before
anyone comes out and says they're
running I think he's the best person to
run I'm not ready to say that but I do
believe that Bernie can defeat Trump a
lot of it doesn't so much have to do
with Bernie but it has to do with the
type of campaign that is actually run
against Trump and as soon as we're over
the midterms as soon as they're done
that's a topic I'm gonna dig into Alex
stones sent a $2 super chat is global
currency viable if so backed by what you
know we already sort of have global
currencies and they are right now they
are crypto currencies and crypto
currencies don't let us evaluate a
global currency on every characteristic
but we do get some ideas of what a
global currency could allow and I think
that global currencies are viable but I
would not necessarily be in favor of a
global government currency because I
think part of what you can say a lot of
negative things about crypto currency
and I've said many of them one of the
things that I do think is a good thing
about crypto currency is that it is not
an asset tied to a particular government
so I would I would not be in favor of a
global government currency ninja x n--
in Jax x sent the $9 99 cent super chat
hey David long time no text I was always
convinced Trump was a Russian puppet
voting tomorrow it's been a rough two
years I've lost friends keep up the good
work I know what you mean I know what
you mean I I don't really unfortunately
I didn't have that many friends who
became trumpets to lose but I definitely
have
touch with some people over them going
trumpets there's no doubt about it David
are sent the five dollar super Chet
David what's your guess on the elections
tomorrow and specifically the Florida
governor's race
I believe Andrew Gilliam is gonna win in
Florida I will do my full predictions on
the program tomorrow but just to kind of
preview that briefly I think the
Democrats do take over the house
I think they pick up 35 to 45 seats is
my guess now by the way I thought Trump
wouldn't win so why you would listen to
my predictions I have no idea but I
think Democrats pick up 35 to 45 seats
in the house and take over control and
then I believe that the in the Senate
it's gonna be plus minus one or two from
where it is right now but I think the
that Republicans are going to maintain a
control in the Senate but I do think in
Florida Gilliam is going to win and I'm
excited about that that's very very
interesting of interesting race
Terry James sent a $5 super chat if the
Democrats are such corporate shills why
did most of them vote against Trump's
tax cuts well you let me steel man the
argument you could argue that for
political reasons the Democrats voted
against Trump's tax cuts but still or
part of the corporate lobbyists
industrial complex status quo in other
ways including being part of the
Republican Democratic handout of money
and and new customers to private
for-profit health insurance companies to
not fundamentally working to change the
lobbyists industrial complex so I think
that you could you could vote against
Trump's tax cuts for political reasons
as a Democrat and still be part of the
corporate shill problem but that doesn't
mean every Democrat is a corporate shill
Jenni kiss sent to a $2 super check
David do you think transness is
appropriation no I don't I don't and I
guess the idea is if you are transgender
are you appropriating someone else's
gender in a way that I guess would be
bad I don't think so enter name sent a
$5 super chat have you
smoked weed if so what was your
experience if not why no I've never
smoked anything just a whether it's
banana leaf or weed or cigarettes or but
you know um the mousepad that's over
there inhaling smoke is bad for you so
I've never I've never smoked ever
anything whoa this is a name sent a five
dollar super jet how do you feel about
the use of the term the left or the
right when used with vitriol to attack
an entire spectrum of political beliefs
it's not about the term to me the left
and the right are useful terms and they
can describe a lot of different
phenomena in a generally useful way
understanding whether someone is
generally on the left or on the right is
a useful characteristic but anytime that
such wide nets are cast to cast
aspersions on so many people whose
beliefs vary and are different I am
absolutely against that Brody Andrew
Mulligan has sent a $2 super chat if
bado loses would you support him versus
Elizabeth Warren in 2020 getting ahead
of ourselves there Brody not not ready
to take that on at this point let's see
what happens tomorrow let's see if
Elizabeth Warren runs let's see if beta
or Roarke plans to run Josh well bull
sent the $5 super chat hey David where
can we see the fake news panel you
participated in at politican online if
anywhere thanks for all you do I have
absolutely no idea I don't know there
were cameras in the room so I it should
be somewhere but I've not seen it online
yet and I don't know why and I don't
know where it is
and maybe I'll do a search for it here
but I'm not sure let's check in on
what's going on with patreon okay we
started the evening with somewhere
around 1630 patrons we're now up to 1650
and I made the promise that if we get to
1675 I would open up the phones and take
a few live calls the phone lines are
currently closed if you want to call in
I encourage
you to make a contribution at
patreon.com slash david pakman show we
normally only take calls on our
broadcast show and we do it on the
Friday show because it's election eve
because I know there's a lot of people
who want to chime in I'm open to opening
up the phone lines and I said 1675
patrons I don't have an unlimited amount
of time tonight so let me just
short-circuit that if we get 10 more
patrons and get to 1660 I'll open up the
phone lines okay and let me say thanks
to a few new patrons John Knapp $2.00 a
month Liz Brown $1 a month
Robert Salazar $1 a month
Peyton Middleton two bucks a month
fishy Pat two bucks a month Courtney
Haynes two bucks a month and newb
errific two bucks a month so it's just
ten more if we get ten more patrons I
will open up the phone lines people can
call in and be great to hear from some
people let's get to a couple other super
chats a farmer Kip $9.99 no question no
comment thank you Spencer Walker 21 $10
at 1 million dollars tax bracket we
should eliminate all loopholes and
deductions but slightly raise the
effective tax rate example if it's 22%
effective for the top one percent make
it 27 percent I'm open to talking about
effective tax rates versus marginal tax
brackets I just think we have to be
consistent I'm not sure I understand so
if you're looking to set a minimum
that's kind of the idea behind some
other proposals that have been there
which are you can have marginal tax
brackets where you pay 40 percent for
everything over 250,000 dollars and 45
percent for everything over a million
dollars but you're right that with
deductions and loopholes your effective
tax rate can end up being much much
lower I would be open to the idea that
no matter what loopholes and deductions
you can take if you make a certain
amount you have to have a certain
minimum effective tax rate
the only problem is that you have to do
a lot of stuff in order to guarantee
that someone whose wages or investment
income is a certain amount that they
actually pay tax on that you have to
eliminate as you're suggesting a lot of
deductions and loopholes which allow
them to lower their rate and I don't
know how practical it is I I wouldn't be
opposed to it I just don't know how
practical that is spread it sent a $2.00
super check what are the books to read
on israel-palestine oh man there's a lot
of good books on this issue but if I
recommend any of them
I'm going to get crushed because people
will say I'm recommending just biased
books and I don't know that there are
any books that people would consider
unbiased I think on the
israeli-palestinian conflict I would
read the full gamut so to understand the
arguments that all sides are making I
would read like a republican right-wing
evangelical defense of israel just to
understand what it is I would look at
what Noam Chomsky has written over the
years I would look at Thomas Friedman
who has very different politics I would
try to understand what he has written
there's so many I'll put a list together
and do a segment audience question and
really think it through because I know
that mentioning specifics are going to
get me straw man and I'm not really
looking to that right now Terry James
two bucks can the Democrats turn a swing
state blue sure depends which state and
you know Florida is an example of a
swing state and Andrew Gilliam may be
about to win the governor's race there
so yeah Democrats can absolutely turn
swing states blue booty blasted sent a
five-dollar super chat do you feel that
Republicans and conservatives are
sociopaths maybe we should stop trying
to appeal to their better natures
because facts don't no I wouldn't say
that they are sociopaths but I would at
this point I believe that anybody who
supports Trump is either acting in bad
faith meaning that they recognize the
absurdity of what he
doing what they have sort of like
personal reasons greed personal benefits
that they would get from from Trump
winning that explain their support for
Trump ignorant of the facts or
cognitively limited and I used to say
mentally ill and I'm realizing that that
that's totally the wrong thing to say
being mentally ill doesn't make you a
trump supporter but I think cognitively
limited is a better way a better way to
say it
Dave video sent to $6 and 66 cent super
chat I am in Massachusetts much like you
as far as the election for governor
tomorrow
who should I not vote for and why
depends on your politics I am NOT voting
for Charlie Baker tomorrow
although among Republicans if you told
me a Republican has to be President
maybe Chama 'not Republican maybe
Charlie Baker is on my list of 10 but
I'm not voting for Charlie Baker and I
have not been hugely impressed with the
J Gonzalez so I actually don't know what
I'm going to do tomorrow I meant to vote
early by the way I know people are gonna
call me out I was not able to just
because I've been working on studio
stuff for a while and it's been I missed
the voting the early voting day in my
neighborhood snake master seven seven
seven five dollars hey David have you
considered talking to Stephen Bunnell
aka destiny again I think he will be
very interested to see how his views
have changed I would be interested I
don't know how his views have changed I
would love it if someone told me I
actually thought it would be he's very
good at analyzing how people do in
debates or conversations with the other
side so I thought it might be fun to
have him on a stream and have him review
my appearance on the Jesse Lee Peterson
program when I was in LA and I would be
interested in having him back and
speaking of Jesse Lee Peters and Ryan
himself says what is a man thanks pal
and all hail blue whale I don't know
what that means I don't know if that's
means blue wave or what but yeah Jesse
Peterson asking me for dictionary
definitions when I was on his show and I
just refused to engage I simply said I'm
not doing dictionary stuff I'm just uh
I'm just not going to do it let's check
in on what's happening on Pay
Triana because we are sort of starting
to run out of time for maybe taking live
calls I said if we got to 1660 patrons I
would open up the phone lines as a
result of John Sellner Hammadi hope I'm
pronouncing that correctly making a $2
pledge and Patrick Butler making a $2
pledge we are now only eight patrons
away eight patrons look at that eight
patrons away from me opening up the
phone lines today so if you're
interested in me taking a few phone
calls and hearing from the audience only
eight more of you need to donate as
little as a dollar and I will do that
okay oh boy I was waiting to see whether
he would arrive and he has g-man seven
one seven oh wait maybe is g-man seven
one seven the same as gr now I'm not
sure but he's asking a question in
Spanish de port occasional Miami
we need a left Spanish David show due to
the election on Brazil to combat that
toxic ideology okay the question is why
does she not love me and of course I
don't know the answer I'm sorry a DIN
child sent a $2.00 super chat why do the
Jesse Lee Peterson interviews knowing he
is he's a ship why do i why am i
agreeing to be interviewed by Jesse Lee
Peterson I think is what they mean
knowing he's a shill honestly I just
think it's funny I don't take it
seriously and if you watched my last
interview I went in not prepared for a
serious debate but just to kind of have
a good time and interestingly the
interview did extraordinarily well and
people wrote to me and they said even
though the guy is is pretty toxic and
not of a worthwhile to talk to you
actually did expose an interesting way
of dealing with these people so I think
it was it was worth my time Dave a
dollar ninety or a pound ninety nine hey
David what are your thoughts on brexit I
would have voted to remain and I am anti
brexit but I am by no means an expert on
the issue
Brandon Roach $5.00 super chat hey have
you thought about covering international
issues more
I have and when we have extra time in
the show and even when we don't I mean
last week we covered the Brazil story
we've covered the growth of extremist
sort of separatist right-wing parties in
Europe but I know that there is a demand
for more international stuff and I'm
gonna try to do a better job of working
that in Jeff Walker with a five Canadian
dollar super chat are more pragmatic
leftist values hurt by the lack of any
true extremists in the Democratic Party
and base do we need more far left voices
to aid this fascinating question I
recently read an article or a viewer
sent it to me and the title of the
article is something like I believe it's
asymmetrical radicalization and it
relates to the Overton Window if you are
familiar with the Overton Window concept
Overton Window is sort of like what's
considered a wide can I go here before
my hands go off screen the Overton
Window is considered the sort of
accepted bounds of debate and you very
often end up with middle ground in
politics that is sort of near the middle
of the Overton Window so mathematically
it would follow that if you shift the
entire debate to the left you might end
up with a more left-wing conclusion a
resolution to an issue if you move the
entire Overton Window to the right that
it will go to the right but the idea of
asymmetrical radicalization is that if
the left doesn't move but the right
moves more to the right the middle the
mean moves to the right and there is a
case to be made that when you have this
asymmetrical radicalization which is
happening almost exclusively on the
right that you do loose and that you end
up with the middle ground appearing to
be or being in in some sort of real way
more to the right so yes I do think to
answer the question Jeff that pragmatic
leftist values are hurt by the fact that
people talk about socialists communists
Leninist Stalinist there really aren't
that many and some of them are sort of
failing to really even be left
practice so I think that that is a real
issue farmer Kip $9.99 says I'm
conservative from rural Arkansas just
wanted to ask your thoughts on a
constitutional republic versus liberal
democracy this is a much bigger issue
than I can get to you today the the
here's the one thing I want to say about
it the debate around constitutional
republic versus liberal democracy is a
fair one it's a real one and it's one
that can be had in good faith
it has unfortunately been perverted in
sidetracked in practice by a lot of
people who are making it a semantic
argument and I think I even mentioned
this on today's show and I think that
that is actually a waste of time and
they they're arguing either out of
ignorance or in bad faith and that
that's a bad idea I'll do a long-form
piece on this once we get through the
couple that we have I think it's a good
topic okay
we are getting close to me opening up
the phone lines let's see where we are
16:54 six more ok just six more patrons
and I'll open up the phone lines and
people can call in Shawn Sepulveda has
made a $2 contribution and John John
Tedrow has made it to a five dollar
contribution and I will say thanks to
Dan balistrari Dan Balestrieri who
increased his pledge from two dollars a
month to five dollars a month not a new
patron but I still appreciate it
appreciate it just six more okay if
people want me to go to the phone lines
and you don't have to want me to do that
but I thought it might be nice and
restart the whole patreon milieu six
more patrons and I will open the phone
lines although I admit I don't have
unlimited time left tonight to keep
screaming let's see who else we can
answer questions from here that's not a
knife this is a knife says for $4.99
nuclear power is preferable to coal
France has 75% of their grid is nuclear
and his cutting edge on nuclear research
look into thorium power yeah like I said
if the question is do I support nuclear
as a bridge to get off of fossil fuels
I'm open to that do I want to be blindly
promoting nuclear in a way that will
take the eye off the ball
No so I think you make a fair point no
apologies 20 asks are you familiar with
court Van Osten he's challenging and
Wagner for her seat in Missouri's second
District he seems to be pretty
progressive and then he goes on to say
but I have seen almost no coverage of
him on progressive youtube do you have
any thoughts on him love the show keep
it up I'm not aware of that and I feel
bad because it seems that I should have
been talking about that I'm gonna look
into that and maybe maybe comment about
it tomorrow phrenic 32 says you should
go on Hugo and Jake's channel haven't
heard of that always open to invitations
to other channels and ecole says wait
are you filming in the majority report
studio no I'm not I don't deny for a
second that I conferred with Sam cedar
about the new studio you will notice
that I have these colored panels behind
me and those are very similar to Sam's
although different colors I have a
screen here which Sam does not have but
yeah I wanted to try something new and
we actually have you know that the
background is new
in the new studio but what's really new
is that I'm actually lit properly I am
lit in a way that separates me from the
background we have the background
separately lit from me and it's not
Sam's studio it is my studio but I'm
trying a similar look and if it doesn't
work we can change it up if people want
some of the white panels to be turned
different colors I can do that
that's very very easy to do so no this
is my studio not Sam's but I there is a
similarity here phobos moon has sent a
four Canadian dollar and twenty cent
super chat with no question or comment
thank you Stephan Pereira has sent a ten
dollar super chat what's a good response
to the notion that we shouldn't have
Medicare for all in the US because we
would trade quality for quantity or have
both but it would cost too much that
there's no evidence backing that up we
there's that it's just there's make if
someone's making that assertion make
them defend it we wouldn't have to trade
quality for quantity I don't know
you've noticed but we already have
inferior health outcomes in a bunch of
different conditions infant mortality is
of the highest in the developed world
there's just no make the person making
the claim defend that because it's
simply not true Joe asks for five bucks
how do I keep such a calm demeanor when
debating or just talking about issues in
general honestly it's sort of being
desensitized to insanity because I've
been doing this for so long and that's
not a good thing actually I've talked
with a lot of friends about this because
they asked they asked me the same thing
and it's not it's it's not something to
be proud of it's that I've become so
desensitized from a lot of this insanity
because I've been doing it for so long
and I don't know I don't know what I
don't know what the end game is quite
quite frankly art Flores says for 9.99
have you seen the jump by the way a lot
of 99s instead of tens and i'm wondering
what that's about is there some reason
why sending a 999 super chat is better
than 10 bucks I don't know art asks have
I seen the John Oliver segment on family
separation that aired last night no also
what artists band are you currently
listening to I'm listening to a ton of
South American bands including a bunch
of Argentinian
bands I like rock artists I like
bedico's I like a lot of different bands
maybe I'll share my my Spotify people
can check it out
Coolio for five bucks says hey David
insomnia I don't know if that's a typo
or if it's in somnus as opposed to in
some insomnia I guess it since ominous
is the greatest podcast on YouTube do
you have any favorites what do you
listen to in your spare time I listen to
almost nothing I listen to I watch
really weird stuff I will watch chess
lectures on YouTube I will watch
beekeeping videos because I'm interested
in maybe doing some backyard beekeeping
in the spring how do I know about
beekeeping it's
gonna be a disaster if I try it
I really don't watch that much stuff
that would be at all relevant to uh to
what I do
Quinn Reid sense of two dollars sent to
two dollars super chat saying just
amazing now it's amazing
that's Jesse Lee Peterson's Jesse Lee
Peterson's catchphrase okay let's see
how we are doing over on patreon 1656
patrons bruno goats has sent a $5 pledge
Quinn Reid has sent a $2 pledge and that
gets us to 1656 patrons we didn't make
it I I said I would take phone calls if
we got to 1656
I'm sorry if if we got to 1675 I then
lowered it and said I would take phone
calls if we got down if we got up to
1660 and we are far away from that and
we didn't make it you know I would just
open the phone lines anyway but I feel
like if I can't be trusted that I will
only take calls if we get to the number
I say why would anybody contribute I
think it would set a really really bad
precedent so I don't think I can do that
and I also by the way had promised if we
got to 1700 which did not happen that I
would play a live game of chess which
would probably be pretty embarrassing
live and we certainly didn't even get
close to that and just as proof you can
see I have Lee chess going here it looks
like someone must be someone from the
audience who wants to play against me
Ragnar you who's rated 1765 yeah I would
should I do it should I just play they
want to play a 10-minute game that's
kind of too long if people want I would
maybe play against Ragnar you I'm gonna
get crushed because I'm rated like 1100
I would do like a five-minute game if
you send me a new challenge maybe I'll
do that just to be nice and to do
something different here but we got one
more patron 16:57 that's Erik Estrada
I love it I don't know if it's that Erik
Estrada I think not spelled a little
differently but I don't know what do
people think should I should I do just
one game of chess if that person sends
me the sends me the challenge people
sing try it no apologies twenty with a
five dollar super chat are you
interested in trying marijuana in any of
its non smokeable forms I never said I
didn't do didn't do that I was asked if
I had smoked stuff
Spencer Walker 21 $2.00 youtuber
nightmare fuel wants to debate you or
Kyle don't know who that is
but best thing is to get in touch
through the through the contact form at
david pakman.com okay let's see
Jack the stripper sent me a 3+2
challenge and now okay I said I would
play Ragnar you I'm gonna do it I'll
just play and I'm gonna get I'm gonna
get crushed here and it's gonna be
embarrassing let's just see if we can do
it Ragnar stepped away they're not gonna
see it while I'm only rated 1075 on the
shorter games this is horrible just see
what happens there's Ragnar see I'm
already confused I don't even know how
to play that response III would know
what to do if Ragnar played f6 because
of something called never play f6 been
fine gold taught me that but I don't not
not totally sure even how to play this
one see how it goes and this is gonna be
embarrassing I don't think I've even
ever played against some one ranked 1666
I could even talk through the logic of
it but then Ragnar could be watching the
stream and I don't know if that I don't
know if that would even make a
difference because he's so much better
than me uh-huh yeah I was about to play
Bishop to g5 but do I not play it now
mmm it's all Castle people care about
this or is this boring I don't even know
I can already tell I'm about to get into
trouble and it's gonna be embarrassing
and it's gonna be really bad
ah he says he muted me to be fair that's
fair
alright so I can talk about what's going
on this is a move that I'm always unsure
about when that pond comes forward to h6
I will sometimes actually retreat with
the bishop back to like d2 or I'll try
to just move the bishop back more useful
if I have a pin but in this case I don't
mmm now I got it figures see I start
getting stuck here where I'm almost not
sure like where to take the initiative
my bishop may end up trapped very very
soon here so you would have them playing
okay on time I think that that's that's
a good thing not thinking too much about
every move since there's only five
minutes
now afterwards we can't even hear me I
was gonna say Ragnar send me a review of
how I played after I would be interested
in hearing that and by the way it looks
like we might have hit 1660 1659 alright
if we get one more patron I will I will
open up the phone lines briefly but I
can't stay too too long yeah so guess
maybe I'll take the pawn don't see a
fork risk with the black knight on d4
immediately yeah bishop right so I'll
take that actually being up a pun
although I'm not anymore right now is
not is not terrible ah do I take this
pawn or do I look for something else I
always like to think of a couple moves
maybe I would put in if I move the
knight up could I later look for a fork
there's no obvious next place for the
night I'll take the pawn it could have
been a huge mistake I'm just not good
enough to even know like what Ragnar is
planning on this basis and I think by
the way that we got no we didn't we're
still at 60 and 59 so I thought once I
thought I saw one more patron come in
what would be next here it would be next
in terms of an attack this King is
pretty well protected his pawn on c5 is
protected by the bishop on e7 the knight
on f6 is protected twice so now there's
an attack on my knight
that is not defended I get the knight
out of the way the Queen can defend the
pawn on b3 how else could I defend the
knight other than moving it I could put
my rook here but of course then just
takes the rook and the rook is
unprotected I could move the knight back
and then the queen I think I got to move
the night back and defend the pawn
mm-hmm all right I think now we
definitely did yeah now we've hit
we've hit 1660 patrons okay so I will
after this game I will open up the phone
lines briefly um thinking about 'if I've
to attack the knight but if the knight
goes away and I take the bishop then the
rook takes my bishop and it's really
just a trade uh still thinking about my
knight on e5 although I just don't know
the obvious next spot because then d7
attacks his Knight attacks the Queen but
he can just take it so I'm not loving
that I'm gonna try attacking this Knight
unlikely he'd really make a mistake
moving the night away he takes my bishop
on h4 got Knight to h4 here's where I
really just lacked creativity like I'm
not sure how to get an attack going that
makes sense right so if I use my queen
to take then I'm no longer defending
this pawn if I use the pawn I'm opening
up the ability to easily check my king
so which do I do
huh if I take the bishop and he takes my
pawn then I could take this rook but
then he takes the rook back that would
be no good pink I'm gonna take with the
pawn doubling my pawns and opening up
the G file which is not good but so time
is becoming a factor here
now let me go back yeah okay so now I
think I have to see if I take the rook
on the a on a one can take my pawn and
then what do i do I don't really know if
I move the Queen out of the way then he
takes my other rook and then I have to
take back and I'm down in rook I think I
have to take it sadly and now this pawn
is undefended it's starting to get ugly
starting to get very very ugly here
primarily because I don't know what I'm
doing okay so now by moving the knight
out of the way now my Bishop Bishop is
attacked and nothing is defending it of
course I can take his Bishop and then
now that's an interesting move if I take
his Bishop and he takes with the rook I
can then put the king in check and the
king is sort of stuck he would have to
move his knight over and I wouldn't be
able to take it that actually seems ok
oh and he had that pre moved already so
that I'm guessing that this could go
wrong I would love to fork over here but
that wouldn't work and I am low on time
so here I go I'm guessing he moves the
knight back because there it does and
now I'm kind of stuck there I'll attack
the Queen just to make it move even
though this pawn is undefended and I'm
guessing that he will take that pawn and
then what do I do
I don't know I don't know
I also don't want my queen to a my queen
to end up trapped which I wonder if it
would if you were to move the rook back
takes the pawn exactly as I thought I
can again check the Queen but then this
pawn becomes available I think I have to
move that pawn is not defended some move
rook here and he takes the pawn it's
actually it's getting pretty bad this is
getting pretty bad I guess I try to take
the pawn just to get something and I'm
out of time sadly all right well listen
I did the best I could that is I
actually you know I'm not totally
displeased given that it was just a few
minute game that that I that how I did
let's open up the phone lines now six
one seven eight three zero forty seven
fifty I'm turning voicemail off and
people should be able to call in let me
see if I can I'm just gonna mute let me
mute just so I can get myself connected
first okay let's see here six one seven
eight three zero 4750 we hit the number
we hit sixteen sixty so let's see if we
can hear from some people don't have too
much time but I do want to you want to
hear from I promised I would so I want
to hear from a few people and let's hope
everything is working correctly here
okay let's go first to okay bro let's go
first to Brody just because he has been
sending he's a member he's been sending
super chats Brody can you hear me mmm
unmute Brody can you hear me now
interesting
somehow Brody seems to be weirdly muted
hmm you there Brody you there now Brody
no no Brody Brody if you call back I
will I'll try to pick up on you again
I'm sorry I don't know what's going on
with the calls I hope this doesn't fail
let's see - six - caller from - six -
can you hear me and can we hear you as
an important important question uh-oh I
wonder what is going on here why can we
not hear anybody let me try
what can I try here let me try calling
back in maybe the problems on my end I
don't even know this would be really
embarrassing if I can't get this working
correctly thank you for calling in to
the David Pakman show
there we go please do not use
speakerphone have your question ready
and listen for David to call out my cell
phone to be able to hear other people
apologies first time first time doing
this let's see I see Brody's back on I'm
gonna try going back to Brody
after I get myself back on and let's see
here
oh and Brody's gone that's weird all
right let me try somebody else five-30
area code caller from five-30 let's hope
this works are you there five-30 yes
David can you hear me I can't go ahead
hey earlier on this year you were
challenged to a debate by a youtuber
that goes by the name of hard bastard
there was $1,500 on the table I was
wondering why you declined that offer I
don't know why I would do it in other
words if the idea is that I can just be
bought to debate with anybody then it's
like what the hell am i doing and it
didn't I vaguely remember people
tweeting me about it and I don't
remember like the original like I don't
remember necessarily getting an email
about it but I do remember tweets about
it and I just didn't even look into it I
mean I don't know 1,500 okay is should I
just be doing anything that people offer
me money for well I wouldn't say
anything as this wondering what the
reason was it didn't want to sell out I
guess yeah I mean listen people I try to
find things to do that are worthwhile
without being paid right in other words
it seems that if something was really
worth doing like it was an awesome
promotional opportunity that
no one would have to offer me money like
if he had more subscribers than you I
don't know I mean I guess you tell me
how it would be more worthwhile oh I
don't know I just thought your put you
know if you're that you know true to
your positions you'd be able to defend
them
well not debating someone is not the
same as not being able to defend a
particular political position is it
can't figure - ok thanks for the call
appreciate it
all right let's go back to Brody and see
if we can hear him Brody are you there
David I am here can you hear me
we can hear you Brody go ahead what's on
your mind awesome hey good job on that
game of chess I love the shell of the
new studio good job thank you sound
great so I was gonna tell you that
overall rolling with an XL series
question so we get people say oh we
can't trust the polls the polls are
wrong obviously we know that obviously
they actively predicted the turnout in
terms of the maths as I the popular vote
so have you seen the latest projections
from 538 regarding d-town powers for the
straight ticket vote and do you have
just kind of anything to those who would
say that the polls are not accurate or
the polls aren't accurate what do you
think about the general sense of the
polls that you've seen and are they an
indicator in any term good bad or
indifferent in your opinion yeah so I
might have missed this earlier but I
said I think that Democrats will pick up
25 I'm sorry 35 to 45 seats in the house
they need
I believe it's uh is it 18 or I forget
the number exactly in order to take over
control that's based on polling right I
mean that's that's based on what the
polarize I think Democrats will not take
over the Senate there are so many races
that are too close to call and within
the margin of error that the polls can
be accurate in that they accurately
predict within the margin of error and
yet you can have a very different
electoral result right so yeah I think
that the polls are gonna get it right
within the margin of error but when you
have so many races within a point we'll
have to wait and see what happens
why not question a stream tomorrow I'm
gonna try to I'm gonna try to I just
have to figure out I can't stream for
five hours straight so I need to either
figure out a way to hand off to someone
else or cut to like CNN coverage and
take breaks or something like that but
I'm gonna hope to do it oh yeah let Pat
step up dude that's ready I'll talk to
him about that all right Brody great to
hear from you thank you so much for the
call have opened up the phone lines at
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's go to our caller from
the 207 area code caller from 207 go
ahead that's you you know the closest
I've ever been to running for elected
office was running for City Council in
Northampton Massachusetts like 12 years
ago and I actually met with a former
city councilor who's now the mayor of
Northampton and as soon as I learned
more about it I decided it's not for me
and yeah would I ever consider running
for elected office yes I would but I
don't know exactly what circumstances
would get me to do it because I've built
something that I really like doing and
unless I'm in a sort of higher elected
office I actually don't know whether I
would have more of an impact just by
doing the show particularly as the show
continues to grow so would I rule it out
like what I say I would never run for
anything no right now I don't really see
anything happening like in the immediate
that would get me to run for anything
okay all right thank you for the call
very much appreciate it let's see who
else I'm just gonna go to area codes I
don't recognize what about like 505
caller from the 505 area code go ahead
hello David this is John can you hear me
yeah go ahead John hey David um so I
just wanted to ask you I had watched
your I don't want to I don't know if
it's if it was a debate about the death
penalty or whatever word you like to use
so I'm a gun owner I own lots of guns
and I'm a responsible gun owner and I
carry a gun you know as as part of mine
I leave the house because it's no
different to me then a multi-tool or a
flashlight so I understand what it what
it's like to own and you
of our arm so if I went rogue for
example when I injured a lot of people
are hurt a lot of people I don't feel
like it would be appropriate for you
know the system to show me empathy and
not give me the death penalty especially
if it we're on camera and you know or in
a church or whatever so I feel like it
helps change the perspective if we kind
of personalize it and say like what have
you killed a bunch of people and why why
wouldn't it be appropriate for you to
receive the death penalty I don't know
how the arguments change at all if we
imagine that it's me versus someone else
like what what what's the relevance of
personalizing it and saying why wouldn't
I - well I wouldn't deserve the death
penalty because I think the government
shouldn't be killing people doesn't
matter whether it's me or someone else
in fact I would argue that there's this
actually relates back to Michael Dukakis
when he was running for president was
asked during I believe it was a debate
what would you do you're against the
definitely what would you do if your
wife and daughter were raped and
murdered or something like that and I
don't remember how he answered it but I
remembered that it was sort of bungled
in that the right answer to
personalizing it is I totally get how if
it was a loved one of yours or of mine
we would want immediately revenge and we
would want to see that person be put to
death I don't know hold on a second oh
dude or we would and and but the problem
is that we shouldn't allow how we would
be feeling if we were in an emergent in
a sort of acutely volatile emotionally
volatile situation dictate what policy
would be because it's the government who
would be doing it sure you know I
knowledge that I'm just I don't want to
use the word revenge I don't feel that
that it the word revenge is the
appropriate word it's just a punishment
to equate
as closely as possible to the level of
the crime like you know if the the
person that was in Vegas that shot all
those people you know 50-plus people
were captured and and alive yeah
wouldn't it be more appropriate I mean
if there's video evidence and on that
scale why why keep that individual alive
and I understand this just slightly if
if if someone had if someone rapes
someone else would you be okay with the
government saying the punishment is that
they now get raped by someone associated
with the quote III I will answer I'm
willing to answer that but I just want
to make the point that if it's on camera
and there's no doubt because I totally
acknowledge that there are people on
death row in their head are people that
have died on desperate yeah or actually
innocent being convicted on bad evidence
but in circumstances where it's on
footage and I got a no doubt I got it I
got it though so I still would be
against it because I don't think the
government should kill people but let
you said that the government is merely
doing what the criminal did that was
your that was that what you said if
someone rapes someone else should would
it would it be okay for the government
to say their punishment is being raped
no it wouldn't so just saying that the
government is merely doing what the
criminal did that's not actually a good
argument right you have to defend it
some other way
sure but my justification as far as
subscribing the death penalty of the
punishment would be that the tax dollars
are not being spent on you know keeping
that individual alive anymore like I
understand that in a lot of cases we're
spending more tax dollars on people on
you know on death row but at the same
time in certain circumstances III so yes
I did even though in practice it's more
expensive to execute someone than to
keep them in prison for life if we could
make it cheaper than you would you think
that would be better how do you make it
cheaper to kill someone than to keep
them on death row or in life and
just expedite the process in those
circumstances where we are able to
expedite the process and how do you X
again it is do you know why it's not it
not faster yes because there's innocent
people that get convicted but again I'm
trying to tie back purely to like if
there's the the most premium of evidence
being you know on on footage you know
like at that level yeah so I think you
know the issue is you're coming at this
from a couple different angles at once
and they sort of overlap and contradict
each other so we've kind of moved from
you first said that you thought it was
okay for the government to it's not
revenge it's merely the government doing
what the criminal did but then when I
explained that that's not such a good
argument then you said well what about
the cost savings even though the cost
savings doesn't actually exist but it
conceivably could if we shortened the
appeals and expedited the system but the
reason we can't do that is because
that's one of the few mechanisms that
exists for innocent people to not end up
getting killed and then you we go back
to your first argument which was well
only in cases where the person has
definitely done it but even DNA evidence
for example has been wrong so do you see
how kind of these are you're kind of
going from one argument to the other and
it's not totally can he coherent and I
say that with peace and love not as an
ad hominem I just think that I don't
know I I would try to put put together
the argument I would maybe focus on one
argument and try to stick with that one
and really defend that one fully that
might be my advice to you now that you
were asking for advice yeah alright
David well I do appreciate you taking my
call and you have a good night okay
thanks for the call very respectful very
respectable glad to hear from them okay
I do have time for one more call and let
me make it the sixty-six area code I do
see that there are thirty people holding
but six to six is gonna have to be the
last one all right six to six what's
going on
hi David can you hear me I can okay cool
my name is long and I'm from California
but I would really look great on Vietnam
so this is a more of a Foreign Affair
question if that's okay with me sure so
my country is a single-point
dictatorship it calls itself a communist
countries but obviously like China and
the previous year reunion it's not
really communist because it never
happened so
as as China and it's its influence
expand with its incredibly fast and
tremendous economic growth how does
countries like well China itself and
surrounding countries who that aren't
democracies how do we sort of push for a
democratic progressive push towards the
government if this is incredible like
influence from dictatorship country like
China yeah what would would where you've
got to look back in history and see it
how those types of dictatorships have
been overthrown and in some places it's
been popular uprisings in other places
it's been out of political necessity in
order to make certain deals with other
countries either for better or for worse
i I don't think that there was one
answer that's a really difficult thing
to say because all there's not been one
sort of pattern for getting out of that
that situation sometimes it's global
alliances of certain kinds other times
it's be it's becoming and this goes you
know it's sort of like starting to think
that if they're better off as
capitalists than the not there's really
no answer and I don't know enough about
the the exact politics of the country to
be able to say for sure I'm sorry I
don't have a better and can I have a
small follow-up yes sir so as you know
living in the u.s. obviously being
educated with a more free education and
being able to understand us how can I
you know a more privileged citizen help
at least push for a more progressive
government of my country without
sparking or risking you know future
conflicts out of you know diplomacy from
the point of view of you as an American
right I mean I'm from Argentina and some
of the best things I've seen done by
Argentinians to try to better Argentina
even though it succeeded only to varying
degrees has been as Americans getting
involved in journalism about
Argentina getting involved in diplomacy
related to Argentina working in State
Department sort of positions interfacing
with Argentina and that I think is one
of the ways you can make the biggest
difference on your home country
this is diplomacy in the in the in the
shoes of the US citizen I'm sorry it's
so so so it's through diplomacy and and
and basically like global networks and
doing diplomatic works as you said it's
absolutely my absolutely okay krispy
thank you so much David all right thank
you really appreciate the call great to
hear from people I don't have more time
today what a stream what a stream a
couple dozen new patrons took a bunch of
calls lost a game of chess I will stream
again that I promise you
thanks to everybody who joined me today